la formule fait du bien on voit enfin la
lumière au bout du tunnel hélas ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'on l'entend la
différence cette fois c'est le variant
au micron selon le premier ministre il
est moins virulent et nous permet
d'espérer que le pire sera bientôt
derrière nous le nombre d'infections
donc le nombre de corps se stabilise et
selon les experts on a atteint il ya
quelques jours un p ce qui permet au
gouvernement de diminuer la pression
d'abord le couvre-feu il sera levé dès
lundi le premier ministre l'avait imposé
la veille du jour de l'an raison de
l'explosion des cas il y aura un coup
reçu sur un jet ski et ex terrain parce
que la situation est extrême mais même
si les hôpitaux sont toujours débordés
il estime que la mesure n'est plus
nécessaire
ensuite la rentrée scolaire la santé
publique ne crois pas que le retour en
classe ce soit trop risqué même si on
s'attend à des ratés ça sera pas parfait
les prochaines semaines vont nécessiter
des ajustements
le ministre de l'éducation misera
notamment sur les tests rapides pour
contrôler la transmission du virus 3
millions 600 mille d'entre eux seront
distribués dès la semaine prochaine dans
les écoles et un plan de contingence est
en place on demande aux parents de nous
des enseignants il devient des
suppléants il est possible que de
manière exceptionnelle en dehors à
dernier recours temporairement
parents viennent surveiller une classe
mais il ya un groupe qui n'est pas prêt
de sabrer le champagne les non vaccinés
dès le 24 janvier ils devront présenter
leur passeport vaccinale dans les
magasins de grande surface de plus de
1500 mètres carrés qui ne sont pas
spécialisés en alimentation ce qu'on
voulait pose surtout c'est à voir cette
exigence la com du premier ministre pour
les plus petits commerces la mise à
l'épreuve n'a donc pas tardé pour le
nouveau patron de la santé publique il
est arrivé il ya deux jours et déjà le
bois l'on impose un nouveau régime
sanitaire au québec moi je me sens très
à l'aise avec les recommandations qui
ont été faites ou mes opinions ont été
dignement tenu en compte les
propriétaires de restaurants de cinéma
et de salles de spectacles devront
patienter encore un peu il est encore
trop tôt pour leur réouverture selon la
santé publique dont la priorité est
toujours de protéger le réseau de la
santé mais la situation pourrait changer
rapidement promet le premier ministre
ici à l'ex boss audio radio canada
québec